مئات من جنود الاحتلال الاسرائيلي شاركوا
في اقتحام ضاحيه السلام داخل مخيم شعفاط
شرقي القدس المحتله
العمليه العسكريه جاءت بهدف هدم شقه سكنيه
تعود لعائله الشهيد عدي التميمي منفذي
هجومي حاجز الشعفات العسكريه ومستوطنه مع
علي ادوميم قبل نحو ثلاثه اشهر
وقد تخللت العمليه العسكريه صدامات مع
شبان المخيم وبلده عناتا ما اسهر عن سقوط
شهيده واصابات بين الفلسطيني
ونعم الوكيل
اسمه تمام مقاومه المقاومه موجوده وهم
اصلا مجرد ما شافوا بوستر عدي التميمي على
بيت عدي التميمي انجن جنونهم انجن جنونهم
تمام يعني لمجرد اجى جندي بده يحرقه تمام
اجى الضابط الكبير سحبوا طواب وحطه بالجيب
قواته الاحتلال التي تحتج جثمان التميمي
مع اكثر من 100 شهيد اخرين تواصل هدم
منازل في مدن اريحا والخليل وبيت لحم
وتجبر اخرين على هدم بيوتهم في القدس
المحتله بحجه عدم حياذتهم رخصه بنا
نتنياهو بن كبير اسمه يشعرون الان بانه
الامور مواتيه في اتجاه ضمن الضفه الغربيه
الناعم المزيد من الاستيطان تهويد المدينه
المقدسه وحسم الصراع تجاه الفلسطينيين في
ظل انشغال الاقليم تواصل قوته الاحتلال
هدم المنازل ضمن سياسته عقاب جماعيا
ومنهجه من وجهه نظر الفلسطينيين وطيف واسع
من المجتمع الدوليه سياسه تشمل كذلك
العمليات القتل والدهم والملاحقه
والاعتقال
فالشاب عمار لحلوح سقط برصاص الاحتلال قرب
مستوطنه كادوميم المقامه على اراضي محافظه
قلقيليه بحجه محاولته تنفيذ عمليه طعن اما
في نابلس فقد اقتحمت قوات الاحتلال قريه
عورته لتامين الوصول المستوطنين لاداء
صلوات تلموديه في موقع يضم مقامات
الاسلاميه بينما اعتقلت عدد من الشبان
بتهمه مقاومه الاحتلال سمير ابو شمالي
الجزيره من مخيم شعفاط شرقيه القدس
المحتله